how many french fries
does mcdonald's make every year
how did you learn to write screenplays
i took a semester of playwriting in
college and also a semester of
screenwriting so in our screen writing
class we had a book called the
screenwriters bible which taught us
the the structure and the technical
aspects of screenwriting and
we
were supposed to have a finished script
coming out of that class
which i did not i i believe my
script was about 50 pages long and and
actually went back recently to go
look at that script to see if there was
something
i could salvage out of that story and it
was just terrible it was so bad
and
and
and i thought that was really funny
because i'm like oh that just means you
know i've grown so much since that first
script that i never finished and and now
my scripts are like i said each script
that i write is is better than the last
one and that's was that's what's
exciting is to see the progression
of
writing
from
a class my first class to to my writing
now
why was it terrible
it
the story just was
didn't really make any sense i guess and
the characters didn't have specific
point of views and they were just
in these scenarios and scenes with
no rhyme or reason
it was just really bad
all across
everything
so they were just sort of like
situations and conflict yeah yeah and
like i said it i never finished it it
was about 45 to 50 pages and and i don't
even think when i looked back on it i
think i read the first two or three
pages and i was like oh i don't i don't
need to finish reading this
shitty script that i wrote back in the
day
so stage plays also you said you learned
to write
why why not focus on that as well
what is it about the screen
so something about stage plays because
even when i was asked by accenture where
do you want to live obviously i had a
couple different cities in mind it was
los angeles new york and chicago
and
i really decided that i
was going to forgo the new york city
theater scene because i didn't feel like
i ever saw
people of color in
broadway plays and so
it just didn't feel like the right place
for me and that i wouldn't get any work
and so but i was always seeing people of
color in commercials and stuff so
that's what made me move to los angeles
and that was the same kind of thinking
um in terms of going into playwriting or
screenwriting i did not see
plays that were written by or for people
of color to be honest
or enough of them but i had like i said
i had watched sattiji three films and i
had seen and i knew bali would have was
a big thing in our culture and so i was
inspired by
the films and the tv that i watched and
it felt more
attainable to me why is it so important
to write a perfect first draft
it's not important to write a perfect
first draft
i
like i said i always write a vomit for a
strap and it's actually terrible
and
writing is all about
rewriting so for me
i'm just trying to get to the page count
and
once i get to 90 i get really excited
and that is cause for celebration and
then i go back and i look at my draft
and it's terrible and so i look through
it and i do my own version of the second
and third drafts of that and then that's
when i get to
send it off to my four or five friends
that i trust to give me critical
smart notes that will actually help move
the script along and then i gather those
notes and i read through them and and i
see if any of the notes are actually
similar and i tackle those notes first
and then
at this point i'm at the fourth fifth
draft of the script and it's getting
there but it's not perfect and then i i
tend to finish a script when it's on its
sixth or seventh draft
that many okay
do you outline
i do outline so
going back to thomas lennon's book
how to
write movies for fun and profit
he has this really great chapter of
outlining where his outlines are
like 20 pages long so if you do a very
specific
long outline where you know exactly what
the scenes are going to be and who the
characters are in each scene you can
transfer that into final draft and then
have just the scenes in there but then
you are writing
the characters in the dialogue so when
you transfer it over to final draft it's
already like 15 20 pages in and so it's
way easier
to
write and finish a script if you have an
amazing outline and you know exactly
where it's going to go and then you can
even hop back and forth so what's
exciting to me is
like i said i i don't write unless i'm
getting
joy from the script and so maybe i want
to write the ending first so then i
write the ending because i already know
what
scenes are necessary to get to the end
so then i just write that ending and
then i work backwards
so your writing process sounds like it
it varies it's not like you start a
script the exact same way every time
it varies with each project and
sometimes i'll just get an idea and i'll
start writing and i'll be like oh i'm
writing where's this gonna go
maybe it goes nowhere but maybe it does
go somewhere and so every project that i
write
it's it's a different process in terms
of getting it down on the page even with
cowboy and indian when i wrote cowboy
and indian i saw it more visually than
with a lot of dialogue
so i just wrote the visions of the
scenes down
and
then
it it was birthed out of that
so going back to the twitter thread from
a few months ago that i saw about the
right way and the wrong way to do
something and sort of you know the film
community and their opinions on it it
sounds like
you just have different styles for each
script that you work on and it all ends
up working out it just there's no real
process that you follow every time for
each one
there's no real process that i follow
and and i think that that's what keeps
it fresh in my mind and
that's what keeps me coming back to
screenwriting with my every story every
idea that i have
there's a new way to approach it and
whether it's
thomas lennon's way of approaching
something which i really connected to
or whether it's just
writing down certain
ideas or visions or
what the cinematography is going to be
then that's that's a whole different way
of looking at approaching a script
with engineering classes did they teach
you the same different ways to
approach
problem solving
so it won't be a b and c every time for
the same problem yes so something that i
went through
after as i was getting my degree was i
was interviewing for a lot of different
jobs and even though i had the accenture
jobs i would go to these interviews to
be like oh maybe they're gonna offer me
more money who knows
and so i was in an interview for
mckinsey consulting which is one of the
big
fancy consulting groups that a lot of
ivy league graduates work for
and they ask
the same type of questions in these
interviews
which
are
[Music]
big
big macro questions that don't
necessarily have a correct answer but
they want to see
your brain process of how you would get
to that answer so
one of the questions that i remember
getting in this
mckinsey consulting interview was
how many french fries
does mcdonald's make every year
so how would you go about answering that
question
and there's different ways to go about
it there's you know you could start with
okay
what does a mcdonald's sign say serving
this many million people
every year you could start from there
and work backwards towards okay how many
how many french fries are in one pack
how many how many people come through
there per day and how many cities are
there in the united states how many
mcdonald's are there in america so you
you go through this process and you have
to say the process out loud to the
interviewer so they can understand your
brain thinking skills and then you get
to a number at the end but it could be a
totally unrealistic number it doesn't
matter what that number is it's about
how you got there
you